une réaction évidemment d'indignation de
consternation est évidemment de révolte
par rapport à 7,7 cet acte ce train qui
s'est produit
j'ai cherché mon collègue à conflans
sainte honorine et qui s'est terminée de
la façon dont vous savez sur la ville
tehrani ce qu'il faut souligner c'est
l'intervention très rapide des forces de
l'ordre qui ont réussi à neutraliser
l'individu à 400 ou 500 mètres de son
effet aujourd'hui l'individu est décédé
l'auteur de ceux de cet acte ignoble est
décédé de cesser ses mots nous tiens un
choc un un choc et moi en tant qu on y
magistrat de la ville en essais c'est un
choc
c'est en attendant une vie de mère dans
notre mission c'est vraiment ce genre de
2,2 de drame on ne souhaite ça n'arrive
jamais et voilà je suis figée j'ai pas
de mots ce soit pour pour ton m'exprimer
pour exprimer ce que je ressens
tellement tellement c'est acté et
ignoble ignoble mais je pense à la
famille de cette victime bien voilà
c'est mais est très très dur